hi there steve kaufman
move my uh
blue snowball a little closer i promised
that i would do these videos on how i
went about learning these different
languages so
uh i'll handle a few in this video and
then
see how many we get done
italian italian is an absolutely
beautiful language it's a beautiful
country it's a country that's made
an amazing contribution to
to history to the culture of the world
and stuff like that i mean who doesn't
want to learn to speak and understand
and enjoy italian
so in the early 90s because i spoke
french and spanish i decided that i
would go after italian and what i did
was i got a a copy of a lingophone set
12 or 16 or 20 i can't remember how many
cassettes
uh reasonably interesting story about an
italian family and what they did and i
just listened and read and
and they had a word list and that's i
did my usual thing listen read and work
on vocabulary and built it up to
a sort of a level
where i could stumble i could read i
then went out and got a lot of readers
in italian some of them were bilingual
texts which i really don't like because
i find it distracting to have to look at
the whole translation whereas really all
i need is just a few words to be
translated so i did some reading in
italian and i kind of had it there and
and i think we might have visited italy
a few times and i sort of stumbled a bit
in italian and and it was never a major
focus
then about seven or eight years ago all
as a part of this whole you know
discovering how convenient the minidisc
player was and then the mp3 player
uh
and along the way i found this website
called naratore which is a audio book
producer
a wonderful family that lives near uh
near verona if i'm not mistaken uh in
italy and they produce uh maurizio is
the voice although he's not the only
voice and they produce wonderful
audiobooks and he has a version of
pinocchio that's just
so well done
and also um i promesisposi by manzoli
which is
the classical novel of italian
literature
and i just did a lot of listening to
italian i can still remember being on
holiday and jogging and listening to
promessi sposey
and it's just it's a wonderful
experience and of course the key in
language learning is to have interesting
content
content drives language learning to my
mind which is something that the
producers of textbooks often don't
realize
so i did a lot of listening
i eventually started reading my first
the first novel that i read in italian
without link without because obviously i
did a lot of work at link to work on
vocabulary but eventually you know you
want to be able to read on your own
without reference to dictionaries or
anything else and the first novel that i
read in italian was this one by alberto
moravia
i mean it was great and there's a it's
always a great sense of achievement when
you finally read that book on your own
without anybody's help uh so i just
and of course we have a wonderful tutor
at link called mariangela who lives in
rome
and so i had lessons with her on skype
and
at first when we spoke because i was
also doing portuguese at the time i was
mixing up spanish and portuguese and
everything else
but uh with more listening and i
listened to the
content that was loaded up then at link
we have our podcast and we have the
material from pepe grillo who is a
famous podcaster in italy and
with more and more exposure it just got
progressively better and then last two
novembers ago
my wife and i spent a month in italy and
i was able to use my italian not as much
as i would have liked because i was with
my wife and we don't speak italian to
each other obviously she doesn't speak
italian
um
but just being in that environment
where no longer is it something that
you're doing in a book or on a tape
you're actually in the environment
you're having coffee you're uh reading
the newspaper you're surrounded by
italian and that just takes it up to
that next level so and that's that's
basically it i've never lived in italy
the longest i've ever spent there was
this one month where we traveled around
but i have done an awful lot of listing
and reading so that was my italian
with regard to korean
uh just as i went after
italian because i had spanish
i felt you know i like the sort of
low-hanging fruit approach
i know japanese and chinese why don't i
do korean so i started doing korean
the problem with korean was that there i
was starting absolutely from scratch i
mean i was in italian too in a way but
with spanish it's so it's it helped so
much whereas korean was more different
from japanese and all the textbooks were
extremely boring uh integrated korean
great thick book like this
full of all kinds of explanations
exercises questions useless notes about
culture i mean
i don't know what is this beginning to
culture education in the school system
in korea who cares all written in
english you know
grammar the clausal connective
background information all kinds of
stuff uh
i don't know i i just you know the
usable portion of the book is probably
you know this book is whatever it is
336 pages long there's probably 20 pages
in here that are useful and i have six
of these books because we didn't have
korean ed link and so i had to find
whatever i could find and i just you
know ordered or found the books and just
basically extracted the
usable to me material which is the
content to listen to and read and yeah
there's some issues of patterns in
korean which i did go over and and one
of the better books actually is produced
here in
at ubc uh by a fellow called professor
ross king i can't remember the name of
it but it it would at least isolate a
bunch of
phrase patterns so you didn't have to go
through lots of lengthy explanations and
diagrams and certainly i never do any
exercises
but mostly what i got out of that too
was the content and their content was
better
i should get the book uh
what was it called ross king
it's uh
what's the name of that publisher in
tuttle tuttle publisher in japan and
they have a very good uh
you know lessons to listen to so i was
actually able to listen to it many many
many many times but ultimately there
just wasn't enough interesting content
in korean to listen to so i spent six
months of lots of listening and reading
and i think my pronunciation is quite
good and what i know i know
but
didn't eventually just lost interest
i then went after portuguese because
it's so close to spanish
and i used again this is
prior to link so i used the teach
yourself books and
and living language and i found
portuguese more different from spanish
than i expect had expected it has
portuguese has all kinds of
you know ficar and uh you know instead
of uh
you know you gusta do you know no not
like me gustas gostado and they're just
a lot of things mora there's there are
quite a few things that are different
that kind of throw you off
and uh plus again the content wasn't
very interesting
so i was kind of stagnating although i
have recollections of uh on our 60th
anniversary we my wife and i went off
golfing and
i was jogging around listening to this
portuguese but i never really was able
to get any traction and the following
year we went to portugal and i couldn't
communicate couldn't understand
and people just spoke to me in english
so but then thereafter we got portuguese
going at link and apollo who was my
tutor
from
brazil she created a lot of good content
about her life down there when she takes
her twins to the zoo and buys them a
candy and i don't know what else 20
little short exercises that kind of i
found interesting because i knew anna
paula and she was also helping me via
skype she was my tutor
uh and very encouraging
and um
then we had this portuguese podcast on
link as well called cafe brazil which
had a lot more words that i could learn
and and we had
we had a learner from portugal who
translated my book and recorded it or
parts of it so i listened to that and i
have never made any difference between
brazilian portuguese and european
portuguese i mean i hear the difference
but i'm trying to learn the language i'm
trying to get exposed to the language
i'm trying to learn words i'm trying to
read and listen to interesting content i
don't care whether they have a
rio de janeiro accent a sao paulo accent
a lisbon accent it doesn't really matter
much to me i just listen to it all a
major breakthrough was when i discovered
these uh
podcasts put out by a radio
portugal
rtf i don't remember what it's called
tsf rtp maybe
there was one uh set of of interviews
uh
called uh
um i can't remember now
at any rate these are interviews that
you can find podcasts of massive
archives of interviews like literally
hundreds
and i listen to lots and lots and lots
lots here in vancouver and then i
remember one particular occasion when i
was driving from from just north of
munich to portugal it's 22 hours or so
in the car the whole way i just listened
to these portuguese interviews very very
interesting interviews and so gradually
the you know the brain starts to get
used to it and of course i have a lot of
the vocabulary from the spanish and from
having worked at it and i have read
portuguese novels i think the first
novel i read was
one by
paulo cuello
and
but i've read books in portuguese and
that's another important thing to do i'm
not going to show you all the books that
i've read but
it is uh it is an important thing to do
to get in there and read so as always
read and listen content that's basically
the the approach i took to those
languages so i'll stop there and in the
next uh in the next video i'll talk
about
whatever languages are left on my list
so thank you for listening bye for now